foreign
[Music]
great to see so many smiling faces
welcome to the app Dev Spotlight session
being a cloud developer in 2023 it's a
truly remarkable experience you get to
code in your choice of language enjoy
portability with containers maximize
Simplicity with serverless and speed up
the entire software development life
cycle with devops principles
but let's face it while giving you all
these exciting opportunities the fast
evolving technology landscape and the
increasing number of cloud services have
also led to unprecedented levels of
complexity
which pose challenges for many
developers too so for example getting
started with a new Cloud can be daunting
and require a huge amount of cognitive
investment
and while you're building your
applications in the cloud you have to
stitch through this Maze of disparate
cloud services and experience constant
context switching due to information
silos like different product
documentation sites or developer sites
and also with this popular notion of
Shifting left the industry's been
putting more and more responsibilities
onto the shoulders of Developers
now at Google Cloud we're committed to
helping developers evolve as the world
changes around us
we want to make your life better by
giving you a new way to Cloud that is
fast easy and secure
so rather than burning our developers
with an ever-growing set of
responsibilities in the software
lifecycle by shifting left
we want to make your life easier by
shifting down providing integrated
assistance pre-configured automations
and out of the box security through our
platform and through our managed
services
so instead of asking you to take care of
all this we can let the platform do the
work for you now let me show you some of
our recent customer successes
with the superior automation brought by
our devops and serverless products
Vodafone a leading technology company
achieves a 80 reduction in development
and deployment time
and Lowe's one of the world's largest
Home Improvement retailers went from one
release every two weeks to over 20
releases every day by automating away
toil with our products and with SRE
practices
that's a 300 times increase
and Gordon's Food Service the largest
family uh operated Food Distribution
Company in North America they increased
the number of deployments from just four
times a year to 2 900 times a year
that's a huge jump and today I'm super
excited to share with you a few more
updates from Google Cloud that can
further help our developers giving you a
new way to to Cloud by shifting down so
you can accomplish more faster more
easily and with improved security
now first of all as I mentioned before
getting started with a new Cloud can be
tough for developers you need to stitch
together lots of different services to
form a complete solution and it's often
hard to identify and learn the best
practices you're you're looking for not
to mention the lack of visibility into
the cost of all these technology choices
and to help developers address this our
team's been hard at work to help lower
barriers to getting started with Google
Cloud
we want to help shift the burden of
getting started with Google Cloud down
into the platform and let the platform
jump start your journey with us
and today I'm happy to announce the
general availability of jump start
solutions a new way to get you started
with Google Cloud
yes
so excited about this jumpstart
Solutions provide developers a
simplified Journey all the way from
searching for your initial project ideas
on Google to getting your first
application up and running on our
platform
with jumpstart Solutions you can quickly
deploy pre-built application and
infrastructure best practices into your
Google Cloud account you can learn
inside an interactive environment right
in the Google Cloud Web console
we also provide cost estimation detailed
reference architectures guides and
walkthroughs for each solution so you
can quickly get familiar with Google
Cloud products and accelerate your path
towards building your own applications
now how about we take a look at this in
action please welcome a new on stage
[Applause]
thank you Gabe hello everyone
I am thrilled to show you what it's like
to explore a jumpstart solution and
since generative AI is a topic of the
hour have you heard of it
let's Taurus solution featuring large
language models so let's say you want to
improve onboarding speed by providing
your employees summaries of technical
documentation or you want to improve the
customer service experience by providing
your agents summaries of previous cases
a customer had these are all perfect
applications use cases for llms so let's
see how jumpstart Solutions can quickly
take us from an idea to a proof of
concept that we could share with our
team
so here we have our catalog of solutions
and we see a generative AI document
summarization solution so let's click to
dive in
so this solution is an architecture
based on Google's Palm model so you see
some more information about the solution
including the price it costs 2.35 per
month but of course
that could be covered by your free trial
credit
you also see the products that are used
in the solution so the jumpstart
solution will provision and configure
these products for you automatically
let's go ahead and click to deploy to
deploy this jumpstart solution into your
project
so we'll be able to configure some of
the options but just know that all the
defaults work just fine
so in just a few minutes we'll have the
solution fully deployed less than the
hours to days it would take if you were
just starting from scratch
a jumpstart solution dramatically
reduces the number of steps you have to
take to get started
so while this is deploying let's go over
the architecture
we kick off the document summarization
process by uploading a new file to
Google Cloud Storage
this solution uses OCR optical character
recognition to extract the text from our
document
then an llm API call to the vertex AI
paw model with a prompt that will
generate a summary per document text
summarization is a new capability
unlocked by these large-scale generative
models
last but not least we've got to do
something with our data right
so we store it in bigquery so another
client or a downstream service can then
use it
let's go back to the deployment
so all within a few minutes and just a
few clicks we go from nothing to having
this fully deployed working generative
AI solution jumpstart Solutions set up
all of this for us
but now what I've deployed a solution
but I'm a developer I have to understand
how all the pieces work together and I
want to make sure it works on my data so
jumpstart Solutions comes to help again
so we've seen the one click to deploy
we've seen the architecture we've seen
the cost transparency now let's talk
about Interactive Learning
so there is an in-console tutorial that
walks you through each step of the
deployment
so the tutorial pops up and it's going
to walk you through step by step
so in this solution we start the
pipeline by uploading a document into
our Google Cloud Storage bucket the
tutorial set one up set us up with one
for us and some sample data to get
started so here's where you could add
your own documents to see how it
performs on your data let's check out
the sample doc provided
so this is quite a long paper on lexical
functions and machine translation Nai
topic I personally find this topic
interesting and I would enjoy reading
the whole thing
but I could see how for most people you
might just want a summary
once we have our sample data the
tutorial guides me to exactly where I
need to go in the UI where I need to
click at every step
so for this architecture we're now going
to go to Cloud functions which handles
the glue code for our data processing
behind the scenes terraform has set us
up with a code and now we can actually
just inspect it it's already deployed
ready to go by clicking through to the
source code
let's go to the last step storing our
data
this solution takes the data extracted
by Google Cloud functions and stores it
into bigquery so we can pull up our
summarization run by running a simple
query right here in the bigquery
Explorer
voila you know that document we just saw
a minute ago it was automatically
summarized and that data was now stored
into this table that the jumpstart
solution created for us all we had to do
was click to deploy
so now that we've seen the stock
summarizer work I can show my team a
working proof of concept with our own
data using large language models and AI
on Google cloud and if my team likes it
and we want to build our own production
version the code is open source ready
for us to fork and modify as needed in
fact here is the repo on GitHub
this application specifically summarizes
documents but we can easily modify this
by adjusting the prompt string so let's
say I wanted to modify this to Bia
extractive q a system or a system that
produces summaries in different
languages easily doable
so we just saw two things with this
jumpstart solution first how quickly you
can deploy pre-built solutions for
common use cases rather than spend hours
even days on initial deployment
second how you can then learn about
these solutions from within the product
and how it works so you can then extend
them so please check out this and all of
the other Solutions in the console and
we cannot wait to hear where these take
you thanks again and back to you Gabe
foreign
demo uh thank you very much Anu it's
amazing to see how quickly you can learn
and build AI applications using
jumpstart Solutions you know I'm
thinking about all the times that I've
wanted to evaluate a new Cloud product
like this and imagine just how how much
time I could have saved by letting
jumpstart Solutions guide me through
this journey instead of having to stitch
all this together on my own now today we
have 14 jumpstart Solutions available in
the Google Cloud console for you to pick
from all of these Solutions are open
source you can play around with it
customize it use it as a starting point
to build your own application you can
also go check them out via the link here
or find them in the Google Cloud console
now with these jumpstart Solutions we
are again Shifting the burden down into
the platform and letting you do the work
letting the platform do the work for you
during this initial learning and
evaluation phase
now talking about AI
as an AI first company Google's been
using AI for many years to help our
products become you know radically more
helpful for for people for businesses
for communities and really for everyone
and with generative AI we're taking the
next step
with a bold and responsible approach we
are reimagining all of our core Cloud
products with generative AI
duet AI as you may all know is the
product that's designed to transform the
way everyone works in Google Cloud
for developers it can help address many
common pain points such as constant
context switching due to information
silos
tedious researching and slow learning
difficulty understanding unfamiliar code
bases and apis and wasted time doing
repetitive tasks
now with duet AI we're helping address
these developer pain points and shifting
down many of the common developer tasks
into the platform task like learning
researching even coding and having duet
AI help take care of them for you
now we announced duet AI in May at i o
in the past three and a half months
trusted testers around the world have
been using duet AI well let's hear what
they have to say about it
[Music]
pretty impressed but give it here for
Google Cloud since it can not only help
with code completion but it can also act
as a chat assistant for you
it was right and quite surprising to see
what AI wiped me back acquired seconds
which took me previously two days till
the search and fine
um
Africa
[Music]
allow me to get the entries that I'm
looking for without having to switch
tabs in my browser or I have to read
dozens of user posts
as an infrastructure engineer I am less
exposed to application coding
but we do it I can easily debug and fix
the bulky code but all of these
sometimes I feel like I'm a software
engineer although I am
foreign
it's wonderful to hear how so many
developers around the world are sharing
what they like about duet Ai and how
duet AI helps them write code more
easily find answers more quickly and
work more efficiently
now as it was announced yesterday we're
now expanding the duet AI preview adding
duet AI capabilities across a wide range
of Google Cloud products and assisting
more Cloud users from developers and
operators to data practitioners and
cyber Security Professionals
and for developers we introduce many new
features to the duet AI preview in
addition to features like code
completion and code generation you'll
Now find duet AI chat assistance in many
Google Cloud products to assist you with
information and advice on coding related
questions and tasks
we've also introduced smart actions
which allow you to perform contextual AI
powered actions like code explanation
and test generation
and to support your compliance needs in
terms of licensing requirements duet AI
provides Source citations so that our
code suggestion provided by duet AI can
be automatically flagged if it directly
quotes at length from a particular
source
now duet AI today supports more than 20
programming languages including go Java
JavaScript python SQL
and thanks to Cloud code you can also
use duet AI in many popular Ides IDs
like vs code IntelliJ pycharm go land
webstorm and more
and to make sure duet AI can better
serve Google Cloud users we've trained
and fine-tuned the foundation models
powering duet AI with Google Cloud
specific content such as documentation
sample code and Google Cloud best
practices
well with that let me welcome Stephanie
on stage to give us a demo of the
developer capabilities of duet AI
Stephanie
[Applause]
thanks so much Gabe hi everyone
now I want you all to imagine that
you're all asked to do a proof of
concept to show that you can
successfully share results stored in the
cloud
from python so how long do you think
that would take
well let's do it right now with duet
ai's help
I want to be able to upload a file and
have an automated test for system
integration tests so let's start with
the local file with results in it and
we'll just try to upload that
I'll type a comment in here which
describes what I want and use the duet
AIS generate code in the upper right
so here I'll go ahead and type out my
command upload a local file to Google
Cloud Storage
and let's see what it comes back with
all right wow it did include and
generate a fair amount of code and here
it includes the code and comments
explaining each step data and cloud
storage is called a blob so the name
upload blob makes sense and line 28 here
is the core of this it uploads a blob
from our source file to cloud storage
okay let's add a call to the new
function with our bucket and file names
upload blob is our new function and here
I'll edit the code to use our bucket
source file name and destination Blog
name so system results
results.yaml and results Dot yaml all
right so this looks promising the next
step is to see if it worked I want to
verify the bucket is empty to start but
I don't know about you all but I don't
remember the command to list objects in
a cloud storage bucket so let's go ahead
and ask duet AI chat
so what is the command to list files in
a cloud storage bucket
see what it comes back with all right
awesome we have the command so let's go
ahead and copy that command and run it
using our bucket name system results
so here we'll copy it down
and add system results
all right
great it looks like there's nothing in
the bucket so now let's go ahead and run
it using our upload script upload.py
all right great there are no errors
let's check the bucket again
okay
it worked so now we've proved that we
can upload a file the next step is to
prove that we can automate it so let's
go ahead and write some unit tests so
who here loves writing unit tests anyone
okay we got like two people just me I'm
just kidding me neither so this is where
duet AI can really come in handy again
so once again we're going to start with
a comment
and we'll ask it to write a test to
validate the upload blob function
and we'll go ahead and click duet AI in
the upper right
and there we go okay awesome so it looks
like it actually generated the entire
test wow
okay and down here it actually left some
things for us to customize and it's
suggesting a main which we can use tab
complete to add it
and you can see here it also includes
yellow lines under the code duet AI can
provide citations for longer sections of
generated code so you can check where it
came from and how it's licensed and in
this case it tells us to use the code
with caution and that the license is
unknown so I'll fill out these variables
now
we have here
bucket name is system results
and then we have our source which is
results.yaml and then let's go ahead and
use a different name for the destination
since this is a test
so now let's try to run this and see if
it worked
all right great that worked out well and
it's easy to upload files to cloud
storage and duet AI helped me figure
that out very quickly so now I'd like to
summarize the code here and send a note
to my team and I'll bet you duet AI can
help with that as well so let's open
duet AI chat and ask it to summarize
this
okay
that works it's kind of long for a note
to my team which I want it to be quick
note so let's try other options like
summarize this in two sentences
all right that's perfect
that's just right and now with duet ai's
help I was able to validate this much
quicker than expected this is a success
and in a few steps we were able to use
duet ai's help to help us create a proof
of concept it helped us generate code to
upload a local results file to cloud
storage get unstuck for any Google Cloud
commands I didn't know write unit tests
and provide possible function calls that
we can include provide citations on Long
blocks of code generated to show source
and Licensing and then summarize the
code so I could share it with my team
quickly you know I get why we call it
duet AI it feels like working as a duet
to build better applications faster with
AI code assistance right in the IDE all
right thank you so much and now back to
you Gabe
[Applause]
thanks Stephanie for that that awesome
demo I just love seeing this stuff it's
great to see duet Ai and action helping
developers get more done faster now so
far we showed you a lot of duet AI
developer capabilities but that's not
all we got some more we want to show so
as a developer
few things are more important than
building apis right fortunately duet AI
is also available in apogee API
management now in apogee duetai can do
things like help developers build API
specifications from simple natural
language prompts through the apogee
plugin integrated into Cloud code
developers can stay in their IDE of
choice they can access apogee and get
duet AI assistance right where they work
now duet AI can respond to the natural
language prompt and quickly generate an
open API spec that supports your
compliance with your Enterprise
standards
you can further improve the spec easily
with assistance from duet AI inside the
code editor
and when you're ready with all that you
can register your API in apigee's API
Hub making it available to your API
consumers
and that's not all with the help of duet
AI you can make your API available in a
chat interface by creating an extension
for vertex AI
duet AI can quickly help generate that
extension and help you secure and govern
the API that you're making available via
chat
now since duet ai's debut at i o a few
months ago we've been actively engaging
with our customers to test do at AI with
their developer teams in real world
scenarios now I'm pleased to welcome
onto the stage Mark Quigley director of
engineering enablement from Wayfair
mark
but first thanks for being here I know
you're leading the development
enablement efforts at uh Wayfair and you
know that's not a very common role in a
lot of organizations it's sort of
interesting that what you're doing there
maybe you tell the audience a bit about
that role and and why Wayfair has
established it yeah thanks for asking
um the rule is really critical because
as you scale and as at a Wayfarer size
the goal is to help all of our engineers
at Wayfair go faster better and be more
engaged and by that we really mean be
happier we find that we get much better
results if all three of those things are
true our teams are spending far more
time on code That Matters to our
customers less time on the boilerplate
stuff makes sense and and I love that
emphasis on being happier I think yeah
it certainly fascinates with me um so
maybe you can tell me a bit like how
does wafer actually measure developer
productivity yeah good question so
mostly we're using the door metrics um
Pioneer by the book accelerate and so
you know you're looking at cycle time
deploy velocity mean time to restore and
uh change failure rate
um those are broad metrics that are
going to really take effect over the
entire developer ecosystem so it's not
something that we can really apply to an
individual developer and at A Team level
you get mixed results but at a global
level across all the way for your scale
we find they produce a really good
indicator of are we in fact making
people faster better and then we use NPS
scores and other engagement surveys to
decide on happier that's great and and
it's awesome to hear door metrics being
so Central to that you know I know the
Dora research team inside of Google puts
a lot of work into the academic research
on that and it's great to see it applied
in practice so I'm also curious like
where do these AI assistance tools like
duet AI fall into the list of Dev
productivity you know efforts that you
and the team are planning to roll out
yeah they Factor very highly so
oftentimes when we're doing our work
we're looking at how can we help them go
faster how can we help our teams be
happier what can we do to get them to
enjoy their job more where can we help
them write better higher quality code
and duet AI gives us a chance to sort of
Target all three of those at once right
we see performance go up we see quality
go up and surprisingly or maybe not so
surprisingly we see the engagement the
happiness scores rise the most people
really like it that's that's great to
hear the early successes and yeah I'm
curious like what are some of the key
challenges that you're looking to solve
with uh to add AI yeah so
it goes back to what I said kind of in
the beginning we want our teams to focus
on product features that matter to our
customers right if I go out to some
place and I say hey I work for Wayfair
they're like oh that's cool what do you
do and I'm like I made logging better I
get this sort of Blank Stare right but
if I can say hey we just released
decorify you can take a picture of your
living room and then quickly generate
images to help you see it in a whole
bunch of different styles Mediterranean
et cetera et cetera their eyes light up
they're excited they're like wow I want
my teams working on those features more
that's great uh although the people who
work on the logging stuff some of them
really love that too no offense to the
lucky folks
um well I mean look that's great I know
during the evaluation process of duet AI
I heard recently that your team did a
hackathon that was intended to measure
the potential productivity gains that
you were getting from this maybe you
could share with the audience a little
bit about what you learned yeah lots of
great feedback depending on the specific
area you look at our productivity
numbers were in the 15 to 55 range which
is huge I'm very happy about that code
quality was neutral or up and we think
that as we gain experience with the tool
we're likely to see those numbers rise
and best of all again like I said the
favorables were really high people said
60 working on more satisfying code 70 uh
felt like they were more engaged with
the work uh less boilerplate activities
uh more time spent on things that
mattered to them and that were
interesting to them to work on so really
excited about that well that's great and
uh so it goes without saying we're here
at uh Google next and lots of googlers
uh here at the event too including some
of the folks who work on duet AI the
product and so if you want to speak to
the folks here what are you looking for
in terms of the road map what would you
love to see the product incorporate over
time yeah so speaking very selfishly for
my role I want to be able to measure the
tool a lot better so I'm looking to see
what kind of metrics can we get about
duet and how it's working the citations
are great but I'd also like to see what
is the acceptance rate so how often are
my Engineers accepting a suggestion from
duet
um I'd like to see how often are those
suggestions sticking all the way through
to the pr that goes to production yeah
but if we think about our Engineers I'm
really excited to see duet expand to the
rest of the software development life
cycle so it's great that it can help me
write code it's great that it can help
me unit test
can it also help me do a PR comment
especially one that you know my product
folks will understand and like and then
maybe one day could it help me answer
back to jira and engage there and take
me out of that Loop because that would
be great well uh you know uh a lot of
great stuff for us to chew on and we're
working closely together we will
continue to do so so look forward to
engaging with you and the team at
Wayfair on making dueta even better for
Wayfair and for everyone in the audience
here so thank you so much thank you
appreciate it
it's it's really great to hear this huge
potential that duet AI has to help wafer
developers move faster and uh you know
as Mark said be happier right such an
important thing so if you'd like to
learn more about all the exciting
developer capabilities of duet Ai and
also join the preview program to test
them out uh please visit this duet AI
webpage cloud.google.com
duet-ai this is where you can get access
to the program we are in fact widening
access to the program as part of this
now
I wanna uh focus on another area here
though AI is very exciting but I want to
talk about something else another aspect
of enabling different application
components to work together
what we call integration now as a
developer you're probably familiar with
how hard it can be to connect your
software with third-party systems like
an Erp or a CRM and yet that's something
we have to do right building such
Integrations this often requires Niche
skills or specialized knowledge of you
know applications and systems like
Salesforce or sap and even if you have
these specialized Knowledge and Skills
building intricate configurations uh you
know it can be very complex consume a
huge amount of your time and the
maintenance of these Integrations can
quickly add lots of overhead now we
believe that integration is something
that should just work and the majority
of the integration work should again be
shifted down to the platform instead of
being shifted left to Developers
now today we are extending our
integration services to include
application integration a new platform
designed to help you automate app to app
Communications across both Google cloud
and third-party software without the
need for complex coding or
configurations
Now application integration offers an
intuitive drag and drop interface and a
growing list of built-in connectors with
these connectors you can easily connect
to Google cloud services and also to
many third-party applications like
Salesforce and sap
and using these capabilities you can now
build complex configurations and data
mappings with a simple point-and-click
configuration
and guess what duet AI also in
application integration simply input a
prompt such as use an incoming purchase
order PDF to automate order processing
and within seconds duet AI will generate
an integration flow
also has your Enterprise context based
on which will automatically generate
flows documentation test cases using
your existing apis and your existing
assets
with application integration you can
build and operate your Integrations with
minimal effort which can save you tons
of time to spend on writing your core
application logic
well
so far we've talked about the various
ways that Google Cloud can help you
build applications faster and easier
but when building applications moving
faster shouldn't be done at the expense
of security
developer security and velocity are
equally important now Google Cloud
security is always at the center of our
product design principles
but instead of Shifting the security
responsibilities left to our developers
again we want to shift these
responsibilities down into the platform
freeing our developers from handling
these tasks themselves
in recent years you know as an example
with the rising trend of remote and
hybrid working companies are hiring more
developers that are widely dispersed
which can lead to increasing security
concerns such as code and data
exfiltration risk and inconsistent
security posture across teams
at the same time it can also cause slow
developer onboarding and reduce
developer productivity because of
disparate developer environments and
tooling
now to help address these challenges we
introduced Cloud workstations last year
at Dex which successfully went into GA
recently
Cloud workstations provides fully
managed development environments with
built-in security best practices it
helps enhance the security of developer
environments while accelerating
developer productivity and onboarding
with Cloud workstations Cloud admins can
easily manage workstation infrastructure
while implementing consistent security
policies and for developers developers
get access to secure and fast
development environments anytime
anywhere via browser or local IDE with
consistent yet customizable tool chains
and the past year since the preview of
cloud workstations we've already seen
many early customer successes
for example L'Oreal the world's largest
Cosmetics company use cloud workstations
and shorten the developer onboarding
time from months to days
Cloud workstations also help make sure
their developers across many different
countries many different teams can work
together in a consistent environment
using consistent yet customizable
tooling
and more importantly with Cloud
workstations they're now able to
implement the same set of security
measures across the dispersed teams to
help make sure they meet the same
security requirements
now besides Cloud workstations
another example of us shifting security
down is around software supply chain
security
Google is an industry leader in this
area for many years we've been working
with the open source Community the
public sector our partners to establish
industry-wide standards and Frameworks
to help protect the software supply
chain
working with open source community
members such as the open source security
Foundation we introduced salsa supply
chain level for software artifacts in
2021. this is an open source software
supply chain security framework it's
adopted by many Enterprises today and
last year we introduced guac graph for
understanding artifact composition clock
right I think chips is going to be next
on on the list of Standards here right
uh yeah but this one is aimed at
democratizing the availability of
information such as software build
security dependency metadata making it
freely accessible and useful for every
organization
now at last year's next we also
introduced Google Cloud's own software
supply chain security solution using
best practices for products like Cloud
build and Cloud deploy
now
to move another step further and help
Google Cloud customers who are using
many of our partner Solutions in their
software delivery cycle today we are
expanding our software supply chain
security best practices even further
integrating those practices with our
partner ecosystem
and today I'm thrilled to announce our
expanded partnership with gitlab now let
me welcome David DeSanto Chief product
officer from gitlab onto the stage David
foreign
thanks
thanks Gabe so one of the biggest risks
to suffer supply chain security is
complex tool chains connected with
digital duct tape
this is one of the top pain points that
are shared with me when speaking with
customers all over the world
and I'm sure it's true for a lot of you
as well
organizations are struggling with so
many tools to manage their software
supply chain and the complexity
increases the risk to security
challenges from code being committed
build pipelines failing and open source
dependencies you don't know the status
of
this complexity creates risk and there's
got to be a better way
so gitlab and Google Cloud are
partnering to provide a seamless
devsecops experience allowing you to
bring software supply chain security to
the Forefront of how you build software
by combining the power of gitlab's
industry-leading Enterprise Dev psychops
platform with Google Cloud software
supply chain security capabilities you
have a secure by default software supply
chain with unparalleled visibility end
to end that will allow you to empower
you and your organization to deliver
secure software faster
this partnership delivers an end-to-end
application development experience that
is deeply integrated together providing
you Best in Class reliability efficiency
and security end to end
this includes everything from Enterprise
agile planning source code management CI
CD and advanced security and compliance
capabilities that are core to gitlab's
depths like Ops platform as well as
continuous container scanning artifact
registry binary authorization and of
course services like Cloud run from
Google Cloud
this will give Google Cloud customers
the ability to easily set up secure
pipelines in gitlab
that automatically connect and deploy to
Google Cloud
with full regionalization and compliance
with DRZ requirements
to leverages seamless integration Google
Cloud customers will be able to launch
the quick start as nationally signing in
to the Google Cloud console
this will you'll see when you sign in
there'll be an option to create a gitlab
project which will allow you to either
create a new gitlab organization or
connect to your existing one
your new gitlab project will be set up
with all the connections needed between
gitlab and Google Cloud allowing you to
immediately begin to secure your
software supply chain and your Google
Cloud targets
in that project you'll be able to easily
configure and manage your deployments
you'll also be able to use pre-populated
component Library
that has the pipeline configurations you
need to ship your code to Google Cloud
there's even a template optimized for
Google cloud based gitlab Runners to
that way you can automatically push your
artifacts directly into the Google Cloud
artifact registry
and of course this partnership comes
with gitlab's best-in-class security and
governance allowing you to fully scan
using our application security scanning
testing
and apply all the governance across the
entire sdlc
this will also give you all the controls
you need to enforce to deliver software
securely and provide all the visibility
you need into violations of your
policies and any exceptions that are
made
and furthermore you'll be able to
seamlessly configure and manage the
Google Cloud artifact registry directly
from within gitlab allowing you to truly
manage your open source strategy
this will enable you to have assured
workloads
and assured sources knowing everything
about your open source packages and
dependencies
I personally find This truly magical to
have an environment where you can start
from planning and work your whole day
all the way through to deployment in
production
the best way to understand what gitlab
and Google Cloud are doing is walk you
through an example
so first let's start with a build
pipeline inside a gitlab with all the
application security testing already
pre-configured
this build pipeline creates several
artifacts these can be images or
binaries
and these artifacts
are produced securely and are signed
with a valid attestation
from there they are then pushed into the
Google Google Cloud artifact registry
where the binary authorization policy
Gates can take full effect
what this means is that only packages
that are approved for running on that
cluster will be deployed if they satisfy
all the security and verification
requirements
so I talked about a lot of stuff really
quickly in a couple of minutes the thing
that I want you to take away from this
is that this is truly exciting giving
you the true visibility across the
entire software development life cycle
we're going to continue to work on this
and if you want to know more
please sign up you can scan and you'll
get updates we're looking to launch this
later in the year and with that thank
you all and back to you Gabe
thanks so much David this integration
between gitlab and Google Cloud it's
going to make end-to-end software supply
chain easier and more accessible than
ever before it's so excellent to see
well we covered a lot in the session
today all the way from jumpstart
Solutions which help you get started
faster with Google Cloud to duet AI your
AI powered collaborator to help you
build applications faster we also took a
look at our new integration platform we
share L'Oreal success story with Cloud
workstations and thanks to David just
now we got an early sneak peek into some
of the awesome Integrations our two
companies are working on around software
supply chain security
and here's a list of sessions uh to help
you learn more about the topics that we
covered today
thank you again to uh you know for
everyone for attending this session I
truly enjoy this 45 minutes uh with all
of you I hope you enjoyed it too
in this AI driven world Google cloud is
committed to helping Developers
by shifting down instead of Shifting
left we want to give you a new way to
Cloud that is fast easy and secure
enjoy the rest of the event thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign